well I hope you all had a wonderful
Thanksgiving and you enjoy the time with
your family I did actually this year
take over the turkey duty so I cooked
the turkey for the Thanksgiving dinner
might have slightly undercooked it if
I'm being totally honest with you
there's a little bit of pink in there
not the whole turkey but just around the
sides around the thighs and and
everything everyone survived nobody died
and anyway rare turkey is a delicacy in
some parts of the world I assume and I
know that that if you listen to this
show on on Wednesday the day the day
before the holiday started you might say
that
well hey Matt you you went on this whole
spiel on Wednesday about the proper way
to prepare a Thanksgiving meal and you
said that if you're a dictator of the
world
you're gonna execute people who don't
properly you know and correctly make a
Thanksgiving meal and then you go and
under cook your turkey what's that all
about well yes but again as I always
stress and I'm very clear about this
there is one rule for me and another
rule for everybody else I do not hold
myself to the same standard that I hold
other people to okay so and and I'm I'm
upfront I'm honest about that so I don't
see what the big deal is putting that to
the side I do have one other thing I
wanted to say in reference to the
holiday before we move on and because
I'm a little I'm a little upset about
something and you could call me
sentimental you could call me
old-fashioned guilty as charged
okay but I am very troubled by the fact
that there were hardly any stampedes or
tramplings on Black Friday this year
we're talking about one of the great
American traditions one of the great
American traditions is as you know
people descending upon big-box retailers
at 5:00 a.m. the day after Thanksgiving
to beat each other to each other to
death over cheap electronics it's
something that back in my day growing up
as a kid it's something that you did as
a family it was a family activity I'll
never forget the first time I saw my
grandmother dropkick a woman over a food
processor that was 65% off and we all
have that special memory right growing
up but we all have a special memory of
the first
that we ourselves committed a felony at
a Best Buy and in fact a kind of a sweet
story for me and I tell this all the
time but I remember my first time I
strangled a man to death with an
extension cord and did get the TV out of
his hands after that did nine years in
prison for but I mean this is just I
don't know it was a tradition it was a
true you know what it was it was a
tradition that helps you kind of
recalibrate refocus after all the stuff
about gratitude on Thanksgiving and all
of that being content and happy you were
able to get that out of your system and
remember that the accumulation of
material things is the point of life and
it's what gives life meaning so it
wasn't just a tradition it was it there
was something real behind it you know
but in recent years there's just been a
lot less of that and then this year
there was a brawl here and there I saw a
few videos but a few arrests but it's
just it's not like it used to be
everyone just orders their stuff on
Amazon and so yeah you still have the
materialism that's alive and well and
that's good but we totally miss out on
the blood lust and the violence and I'm
sorry maybe I'm stuck in the past but
it's just not the same that's my that's
my thing
okay traditionalist I've always I've
always been that way I guess all we can
do though is is move on much to discuss
on this Monday including a surprising
and inspiring actually inspiring I'm
switching out of sarcasm mode now so now
we're into there's a there's a actually
inspiring moment in a college football
game on Saturday an inspiring moment
that of course also upset plenty of
people on the left as they tend to get
upset about things especially good
things so we'll talk about that but
first a word from ancestry DNA it's
really hard to overstate the importance
of knowing where you come from knowing
your history I think maybe in times past
people were more connected to their past
they knew more about it it's just there
was a more direct and explicit line
between the where you are now and and
where your family was but these days the
past can tend to feel well distant and
that's where ancestry DNA comes in to
connect you with your
and with your family ancestry DNA
doesn't just tell you which countries
you come from but also can pinpoint the
specific regions within them giving you
insightful Geographic detail about your
history you trace the paths of your
recent ancestors learn how and why your
family moved from place to place around
the world from discovering origins and
over five hundred regions to the most to
the most connections to living relatives
no other DNA tests deliver such a unique
and interactive experience only ancestry
DNA uses the world's largest family
history database to give a deeper and
more detailed family family story DNA
story you can combine what you learn
from your DNA with over a hundred
million family trees and billions of
records that will give you an even more
insight into your history so you could
save big on ancestry DNA with holiday
special pricing and you could spark
meaningful conversations around the
holiday dinner table give the gift that
can unwrap their history head to my URL
at ancestry.com slash mat to get your
ancestry DNA kit on sale today
that's an sis ancestry.com slash mat
ancestry.com slash mat all right the
great ohio state running back
JK Dobbins had another big game on
Saturday against Michigan and then
towards the end of the game wasn't a
very interesting game it was kind of a
blowout but the most interesting thing
that happened was towards the end of the
game the announcer Gus Johnson surprised
everybody with an anecdote the kind of
anecdote you don't hear very often at
football games an anecdote about Dobbins
and his mother well just take a listen
to this 211 yards rushing
what does this kid not do he's turning
the clock out in between the tackles and
then BAM lightning on the outside the
explosiveness to go down and then up and
over the top to put that ball over the
goal line for a touchdown we'll add a
four JK Dobbins absolute dominant
performance from Dobbins and this
offensive line
JK Dobbins is mom Maya
[Applause]
became pregnant when she was 18 years
old
she went to the doctor because she was
thinking
boarding the baby but changed her mind
that baby turned out to be that young
man JK Dobbins who she calls her miracle
baby now as you might expect some people
on the Left were watching this game and
didn't like that that story was shared
and they expressed frustration on social
media and that's actually how I first
heard about it was people complaining
about it
I watched part of the game as it aired
but I missed that moment originally when
it when it was when it happened there
was an accusation that Gus Johnson was
intruding on the privacy of Dobbins and
his mother or sharing something that
wasn't meant to be shared wasn't his
place to share but I think we can be
pretty sure that if Gunz Gus Johnson
knows about this detail it's because she
shares it openly and isn't embarrassed
about it why should she be why should
she be better no reason to be
embarrassed she chose life and now her
son has grown into a man that she's
extremely proud of and it's a wonderful
story and this really shows I think when
you look at this and the two different
reactions to it from the pro-abortion
and pro-life side it shows the the
poverty of the pro-abortion side I think
I don't mean the economic poverty I mean
the intellectual and moral poverty
because pro-lifers what we're saying is
simply that every human has an innate
right to life and one of the reasons why
that right must be protected especially
as it concerns baby and babies in the
womb is that babies deserve a chance
they deserve a chance to live and to
grow and to make choices and to become
the kind of person that they're going to
be Dobbins was given that chance took
that chance and that was granted to him
and it became one of the best college
athletes in the country it would have
been a tragedy for him to have been
deprived of that chance it would have
been a tragedy and also just incorrect
as it turns out to assume that he'll
amount to nothing that his life will be
a pointless waste because he was born in
less than ideal circumstances
you can't close the book on a whole
human life when you haven't even read a
page yet
that's obviously a mistake so this is
all about potential unborn children are
full of potential they are not potential
people they are people with potential as
the pro-life slogan goes but I'm almost
tempted to say that the distinction
doesn't matter you know fine go ahead
and call them potential people they
aren't so I'm not ceding that argument
at all they aren't potential people they
are there are people with potential
that's certainly my position but for the
sake of arguments I'm almost tempted to
say fine what difference does it make
it's just a potential person well what
do you mean just that's a potential
person right every every great athlete
every great leader every scientist
doctor poet humanitarian civil rights
Crusader and so on all of these people
were at one point quote-unquote fetuses
before they they did those great things
before they made something of themselves
they had only the potential for them
unrealized potential if you want to say
that they were potential rather than
they had potential I don't see how that
changes anything
now the poverty of the pro-abortion side
is in saying that all of that potential
doesn't mean anything or doesn't count
or it shouldn't be weighed it amounts to
nothing like we shouldn't even take it
into consideration the poverty is in
seeing this life with potential and yet
considering it to neither to be neither
life nor potential considering
considering it only a burden or a
parasite
problem to be solved that's how the
pro-abortion side would look at somebody
like JK Dobbins they would say that in
the womb he was a problem to be solved
not a person and certainly not a person
with this incredible potential to do
extraordinary things and it's such an
empty and bleak
official view of human life so I'm glad
that we have a guy like Dobbins around
to demonstrate that the the analogy that
I've made before in a lot of the talks
that I give on pro-life issues maybe
I've made this analogy on the show
before I don't know probably have it's
not a it's not a perfect analogy by any
stretch but imagine firma but we talk
about potential right well imagine for a
moment that you had a winning lottery
ticket for 50 million dollars and you
hadn't cashed it in yet so you have the
50 million dollar lottery ticket you
just watched the the drawing on the news
you found out that you won and so you
know that this is going to be 50 million
dollars but it's not yet right now it is
the potential for 50 million dollars but
what if on the way to the lottery office
to cash in that ticket which again it's
just the potential for 50 million
dollars it's not 50 million dollars yet
what if on the way I were to run up and
grab that ticket from you and destroy it
let's say I ate it right in front of you
for no reason because I'm insane how
would you react would you react as
though you just lost a receipt paper
which is technically all it was or would
you react as though you just lost fifty
million dollars
if you if you now that I've taken that
take it from you and destroyed it
what do I owe you do I owe you a receipt
paper like can I just grab a crumpled up
right aid receipt from my pocket and
give it to you in fair's fair or even or
would you say I now owe you 50 million
dollars
well we all know they answer that
question because my point is when it
comes to something like money and a
lottery ticket you would see no
distinction between the potential for
fifty million dollars and fifty million
dollars it would do no good for me to
try to do this reductive absurd
materialistic thing with with the
lottery ticket which is after all just
material and for me to say yeah
technically it's just potential because
in your mind you would say so
same what difference does that make it's
basically the same thing and so if we
can make that calculation when it comes
to a lottery ticket why can't we do it
with a life a human life so my point is
this this this argument about is it a
potential person or a or an actual
person maybe what either way I mean even
if you could even if you could
demonstrate which you can't because the
unborn child is a human person I
emphasize that again for the tenth time
but sake of argument even if you could
somehow demonstrate or prove or convince
me that the unborn human is not a person
but is just a potential person even if
you could convince me of that you still
have not convinced me that it would be
okay or moral or should be legal to kill
that potential person
you see you see what I'm saying that on
the pro-abortion side you really have
two things you need to proof two very
significant things you need to prove
first you need to prove that the unborn
child is not a person but a potential
person which you can't do but even if
you could now you've got the next step
you've really still got all your work in
front of you because now you have to
prove that it's therefore okay to kill
that potential person because to me they
don't seem to logically follow just
because you can prove something isn't a
person doesn't mean you can kill it in
fact we we could all come up with
examples of things of living creatures
that are not people and yet we would say
you shouldn't kill like for example your
neighbor's dog not a person not even a
potential person yet you would say if
you kill that non person creature you
should go to jail so the simple fact
that something is not a person doesn't
mean you can kill him
so you gotta you gotta prove that to me
I don't think you can so you've got
these two enormous logical leaps you
need to make one is that a person is not
a person but a potential person and the
other is that it's okay to kill it I
could spot you the first leap I could
say go ahead I'll give you that it's not
a person final I'll let you pretend that
and now you're stranded out on an island
because I'm not going to give you the
next leap and I don't think you can make
that argument this is how bad the
pro-abortion argument is that you could
even I think it's a mistake to argue it
on the pro-abortion terms but you could
even argue it on their terms and they
would still lose that's how bad their
argument is okay it's a potential yeah a
potential potential person think about
that how extraordinary is that
all right
what else we got here okay and and then
there's this watch and by the way you
know I should understand and to get hot
I got Lana I got hairy legs that turned
that that that that that turned about
blonde in the Sun and the kids used to
come up and reach in the pool and rub my
leg down
so it was trade and then watch the hair
come back up again they look at so I
learned about roaches I learned about
kids jumping on my lap and I'd love kids
jumping on my lap yeah I have I have
nothing to add here not much to
elaborate on just Joe Biden telling a
story about children rubbing his
bleached-blonde leg hair in the pool I
was traumatized by this image and I
thought it only fair for me to share the
trauma around because I had to
experience it and now I want you to
carry this burden I want you to help me
carry this cross the only thing I'll say
about Joe Biden I know the general
feeling now is that Biden is really
coming undone mentally and if he's the
guy in the general he'll he'll get
trounced by Trump that's the feeling
among many Republicans and I see the
logic of it and it maybe is even true
he's an extremely weak candidate in more
ways than one so I could see how you
would say well he's gonna do very poorly
but I will caution one thing one word of
warning for any Republican or
conservative who gets overconfident
about it it is possible that Biden's
craziness is baked into the cake at this
point that's kind it's the feeling that
I'm getting about him now that's part of
the reason why Trump is not harmed by a
lot of the things that he does and says
that would destroy any other politician
or candidate this is what's so
frustrating for Democrats and has been
for ever since it came on the scene that
he appears to be he appears to be
impervious because it doesn't mean say
whatever he wants and things that he
says and does it would just be huge be
considered huge gaffes and and and
politically ruinous for other candidates
it's not for
him Trump can get away with soot day
saying and doing all kinds of things
because it's baked in and we kind of
know well that's that's just Trump being
Trump that's what he does and that's how
he acts I mean over the weekend just as
an example maybe you saw this Trump
tweeted a picture of himself his face
photoshopped on the body of on the on
rocky Balboa's shirtless body and no no
comment or anything in just the picture
he tweeted and conservatives laughed
about it and said oh that's our
president being silly but of course and
really it's not a big deal so fine I
guess it's just funny but of course we
all know we all know without a doubt
that if Obama had tweeted a picture of
himself photoshopped onto the shirtless
body of a boxer we would all be saying
that he's lost his mind he's an
egomaniacal crazy person who's unfit for
office that's what every conservative
would be saying without a doubt there's
no point than don't deny it don't try to
denying and we know it's true let let's
just be honest with each other here
there's a lot of that's just one example
there's a ton of stuff that Trump does
and says that if if Obama were to have
done or done or said that we would we
would still be talking about it now
years later but it's different with
Trump somehow because we're just used to
this stuff and so it's it's it's not the
same thing right it's not I mean imagine
if Nancy Pelosi tweeted a picture of her
face photoshopped on the body of like a
swimsuit model now that it would that
would be more disturbing I think on a
number of levels but it would really
technically be the same thing right yet
she could never get away with that but
four trumpets baked in for better or
worse it's baked in well I wonder if if
Biden won't benefit in a similar way I
wonder if he hasn't said enough crazy
stuff at this point that people are just
like yeah you know that's Biden for you
it's creepy and weird and I don't know
what the hell he's talking about but
that's just Biden
I'm thinking that might be the case I
don't know in a general election between
these two we'll just I I think well at
the very least we'll all be entertained
by it if you can imagine you can you
imagine a debate between Joe Biden and
and and Donald Trump two and a half
hours of these two just gone back and
forth who knows what will happen by the
end of it one of them is gonna be like
yodeling the other one's gonna be doing
the who knows one of them's gonna be
doing somersaults on the ground I it's
just gonna be it's good you can't even
predict it you have no idea
you follow both of these guys and their
train of thought and just you give them
and who knows where it's good I think
it'll be entertaining and and I wonder
if like I said it kind of breaks all the
rules of politics and Biden's got
himself to a point where he can
basically say whatever he wants because
it's what everyone expects anyway
there there
of providing a blueprint I guess for
other politicians because traditionally
the idea is if you're a politician
you've got to be completely buttoned up
and you have to be completely scripted
and everything's got to be totally clean
and there can't be any skeletons that
are well you might have skeletons but
you can't let anyone see them and every
answer you give has to be perfect and
has to be very diplomatic and and
calculated and considered the other
option is the way extreme end of that
the other the of the opposite end of
that spectrum
and to just be nuts all the time
and then it's just who you are so
alright we'll see we'll see how that
goes
one other thing I wanted to talk about
this briefly article in The Daily wire
headline Angela Merkel says freedom of
expression has its limits
and must be regulated to keep society
free reading a little bit from a German
Chancellor Angela Merkel spoke out
against free speech this week suggesting
the government can and should regulate
what people say to keep society free
Merkel speaking at an event for the
German chamber of Industry and Commerce
in Berlin stubbled up the stairs before
taking the podium and suggesting the
government bans speech she considers
extreme and decrying freedom of
expression she said we have freedom of
expression in our country for all those
who claim they can no longer express
their opinion I say this to them if you
express a pronounced opinion you must
live with the fact that you will be
contradicted expressing an opinion does
not come at zero cost okay so far so
good you can be contradicted on your
opinion we can all agree with that I
think right but and this is where we go
off the rails freedom of speech freedom
of expression has its limits those
limits begin those limits begin where
hatred is spread they begin where the
dignity of other people has violated the
house will and must oppose extreme
speech otherwise our society will no
longer be that for free society that it
was so then we descend very rapidly into
blatant Orwellian dystopian propaganda
where the way to have a free society is
to restrict freedom and that's what
she's talking about here and I think
what we take from this well a couple of
things number one the idea that another
person's dignity can be violated because
of something that said to them or about
them
that's that's not how it works now you
could violate your own dignity by the
things that you say and the way you
conduct yourself
that's true but mine see that's a thing
my dignity what what whatever little bit
of it I have it's still intact cannot be
affected by anything you say to me or
about me you cannot do anything to my
dignity that's something that it can
only go away if I willingly forfeit it
sacrifice it other than that you can't
do anything to it
now
you can in a sense violate my dignity
but but this is the irony the way that
the government can violate my dignity as
a human being is to take away my
freedoms and my liberty now I will still
I will still have that dignity because
it's inherent to me as a person
but you can in a sense violated by not
acknowledging the fact that I am meant
to be free as a human being
I have an inherent right to that but
certainly there's nothing you could say
there's no opinion you could express
where where all of a sudden my dignity
has been violated and then she talks
about hatred and this is the problem
with with we take this word hatred and
the way that we use at these days just
this blanket thing
and and it really really the idea that
even I mean starting with the idea that
hatred in and of itself is automatically
terrible doesn't dependent you say well
those limits that you have limits on
speech as soon as you start spreading
hatred well doesn't it at least matter
what you're spreading hatred of what if
I'm spreading hatred of oppression what
if I'm spreading hatred of of greed what
if it's hatred of you know of rape and
murder and it isn't okay to hate those
things well of course it is but we can't
acknowledge that because that gets in
the way this of this oversimplified
dichotomy we have that hatred bad well
no that's just not the case there are
things that we as human beings should
absolutely hate and that's a if you want
to put it this way that's a hatred that
should be spread we should hate hateful
things we should hate bad things evil
things but even if even if someone is
expressing hatred in inappropriate
hatred an immoral hatred
you know hatred of another person of a
group of people well that's not good
but why shouldn't they have the right to
say that
and don't we all want to know
that's another one of the ironies of the
people that want to restrict free speech
because they're afraid of the so-called
hateful bigots that are going to use
free speech to spread their bigotry
well even leaving aside the issues of
free speech and the First Amendment
which of course doesn't apply in Germany
but at least in this country it does but
even leaving that aside you're kind of
undercutting your own agenda in a way
because if there are there are actual
hateful bigots out there in the in the
country in the world then you want to
know who they are
isn't it better to know that
if that's who they are don't you want
them because otherwise you're just
sending them into hiding they still
exist
but now you don't know
this is what I always say about the
issue of the rights of business owners
and I've always been very consistent
that Christian business owner should
have the right to run their businesses
as they see fit and if they don't want
to be involved in say a gay wedding they
should have that right the response is
always well if we give this right to
business owners with respect to gay
marriages and so on then what if you
have a racist business owner that says
he doesn't want to be involved in the
you know the wedding of a of a black
couple or of a mixed couple and the
first response to that is that these are
those are not analogous things so it is
possible to protect the right of a
Christian Christian business owner to
run his business according to his
religious beliefs without also allowing
businesses to discriminate based on race
it is possible to draw that line of
distinction and in fact we had done that
for many decades in this country so it's
a vet it's an invalid argument already
but my personal opinion is yeah let
people let a business owner should have
the right to refuse service to anyone
for any reason that's the way I look at
they have that right it's their business
it's their property it's their good
their service
be conscripted into service for someone
they should have the right this is
freedom of association and also if there
is a business owner out there who is so
racist such a bigot that he would he's
willing to advertise that fact
and put it out there and say well we're
not going to serve this or that race let
them do it right don't you want to know
if you have a business owner like that
in your community and and you're going
to that place and your support is
personal wouldn't you prefer if they
just announce it and make that clear so
you could stop supporting them wouldn't
don't you want to know that so business
owner comes out and says oh we're not
gonna serve black people let's say
they're gonna be out of business by
tomorrow because the markets not gonna
not going to support that so they
announce it they're punished by the
market problem solved and you could say
the same thing when it comes to free
speech even aside and we don't really
need to get into this because the rights
should speak for themselves but even
aside from that if somebody wants to
advertise their hate or bigotry or
whatever let them do it and then we all
know and you
decide how or if you want to associate
with that person that's how freedom
works
it's a wonderful thing so Friday was
just insane he didn't catch it we put
together a Black Friday promotion where
all of our plans are for daily wire.com
were 50% off and and we learned
something and that is that you all
really like coupons and who doesn't
because because we all like coupons more
of you became subscribers on Friday in a
single day than in any given month in
history of the daily wire that's how
successful this was but then Saturday
came along and our customer support team
they were very busy god bless him a lot
of you missed the deal on Friday and
wanted it wanted it to still be honored
lots of current subscribers were
confused about whether or not it worked
on upgrades and all this kind of stuff
so we're bringing it back that's right
one more day of this magnificent
promotion when you become a subscriber
to daily wire comm today today you'll
get 50% off when you use the promo code
DW 50 so we're bringing this back again
DW 50 50% off as an insider you'll get
access to our live shows you get two
extra hours of been every day alongside
many other things when you're an insider
plus you get all of that and the
glorious left is tears tumblr which you
can see behind me with our new tier of
all-access you get to chat with me and
the rest of the team here at the daily
wire I would do these chats all the time
they're a lot of fun and so you're
missing out if you don't get a chance to
do that and to clarify for current
subscribers you can use this Rob grades
as well so what are you waiting for get
over to the daily wired.com daily
wired.com right now use promo code DW 50
before time runs out we're not running
any of that cyber Tuesday nonsense okay
so this is this is really it right now
you got to go right now this is your
last chance
that's DW 50 daily wire.com okay finally
before we wrap up order to mention
a tweet from the Twitter account history
lovers Club here it is I'll show it to
you
this was the tweet couple days ago it
says fathers were not allowed in the
delivery room until Jay and Margie
Hathaway found a doctor that allowed Jay
to be present for the birth of their son
James in 1965 the couple went on to
found the American Academy of husband
coached childbirth I saw this tweet the
other day and
to say J
and thank you you jerk we had a good
thing going Jay we men did I mean the
wives took care of the childbirth men
went to the smoking-room had some scotch
or bourbon smoke the cigar waited for
all the drama to be over you know we
were called in once it was all done
everything's done finished cleaned up we
come in we say hi to baby give the mom a
high five nicely done
go back finish the cigar check back in
with the baby once it turns you know 16
years old or something it was a sweet
deal Jay and and and you you ruined it
and now we have to be in the room the
whole time on that little chair slash
prison cot thing they give the dads and
if you're there overnight they give you
like an old newspaper as a blanket that
you're curled up with a sack of quarters
for a pillow the nurse comes in every
five and a half seconds for some reason
during the night is super loud for no
reason okay I'm here to take everyone's
blood pressure she's banging pots and
pans waking everybody up on purpose I've
been through this now with all four kids
and every time this is why this tweet
jumped out at me every time you lose I
always think and every man thinks this
so listen I tell you right now if you're
if you're a woman you're watching your
scandalized by what I'm saying
and you think I know my husband he
wanted to be there I'm telling you every
man has had this thought every single
one don't let your husband lie to you
sorry fellows I got a I got a reveal
this is just the truth
we all think this we all think man if I
was only born 70 years ago I could be in
the smoking-room right now
you know but we never knew who to blame
for this change and now we know it was
Jay Jay you suck-up I'm just kidding of
course there's no place I'd rather be
than in that room getting to see my
beloved children take their first
breaths I mean no whiskey no whiskey
could be better than that
maybe a pappi 23 but that's cream of the
crop you know so I'm kidding again sort
of but not really and we'll leave it
there
thanks everybody for watching have a
great day Godspeed the Matt Walsh show
is produced by Sean Hampton executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producer Mathis
Glover supervising producer Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens editor Donovan Fowler audio
mixer Mike Cora Mina the Matt Walsh show
is a daily wire production copyright day
Lee Weyer 2019 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]